Why do we need to trust
the operating system?
And I'm going to talk about exactly
what does it mean to trust a system, but
that sort of differentiates
an operating system from
other applications that
may not be trusted.
So, why do we need to trust it?
In fact,
not only we need to trust it but
we actually also call it
a trusted computing base.
So let's see why do we call it a TCB or
It is the base in some sense.
If you don't directly want to
deal with the hardware,
we set applications on top
of the operating system.
So the operating system really is
the computing base that is seen
by the applications or
the user processes.
The need to trust to the operating
system comes from the fact
that we giving it
the keys to the kingdom.
Keys to the kingdom here are direct
control of all the physical resources.
So the operating system in some sense is
able to access anything that we have and
then it's the job of the operating
system to make sure that
these resources, or whatever,
high level resources we implement
using the low level physical resources
get accessed by the correct users in
the system or the correct applications.
And if you're going to make someone
sort of the in charge or the controller,
you better be able to trusted that it's
going to do what it's supposed to do.
Otherwise, the results that you
going to have, you will not like them.
So that's why there's need to
trust an operating system.
So what the exactly does it mean for
us to be able to trust
the operating system.
So what are the requirements that should
be met by this trusted computing base
that we say sets an important
role in protecting our resources?
First of all, the operating system
absolutely has to be between
the untrusted applications and
the physical hardware
resources that we have.
This is called complete mediation.
Think about the request coming
from an untrusted application and
this request is for a resource that is
being requested by the application.
It has to go through
the operating system.
The operating system has
to mediate this request and
you can think about
why that's necessary.
It's necessary because we had
the operating system has to check
that the resource of
the request actually has access
is allowed to gain
access to this resource.
And for that check to happen,
the operating system has to become
between the request and the resource.
So that's called complete mediation.
Okay, you can't get to any resource that
need to be protected without actually
going through the operating system.
So trusted system is always
going to take a look
at any request before it actually
reaches the resource, and
the source of that request is
able to access that resource.
So the complete mediation
requirement is the first one.
The second requirement a trusted
computing base has to meet is,
what we call, it has to be tamper-proof.
In fact, we going to spend bunch
of time how to achieve that,
or how to meet that requirement.
The reason it has to be tamper proof is
that we're talking about untrusted code
and in the trusted computing base
of the trusted operating system.
Well, if the untrusted code can tamper
with the trusted operating system,
you can't trust anymore.
The untrusted code tampers with it,
changes it to do whatever it wants done.
In particular again, access to resources
that perhaps were not meant for
this untrusted application, which may
be compromised, could be malicious.
Third requirement is the so
called correctness requirement.
If you going to call a system trusted,
you going to completely rely
on it to make sure that you're protected
resources get used in a proper way.
Then however it does that,
whatever functionalities implemented by
the trusted computing base,
it should be done correctly.
Because if there is a vulnerability or
a bug or
some error in the trusted computing
base or the operating system.
I said it has the keys to the kingdom.
So, we said operating
system has to be trusted.
Now we know what it means for
it to be trusted.
You shouldn't be able to bypass it.
Okay?
That's complete mediation.
You have to go through it.
You can't alter or change it,
if you are an untrusted application.
And whatever functionality it
implements, that's done correctly.